♪ ♪
>> Jesse: WHAT TOOK HIM SO
LONG?
RADICAL MANHATTAN D.A. FINALLY
DROPPING THE BOGUS SECOND-DEGREE
MURDER CHARGE AGAINST THE
HARDWORKING BODEGA CLERK WHO WAS
ACTING IN SELF-DEFENSE WHEN HE
STABBED A CAREER CRIMINAL FELON.
CELEBRATING THE NEWS WHILE
SOUNDING OFF ON THE CRIME WAVE.
>> I THINK THIS CASE, WE HAD AN
INNOCENT, HARDWORKING NEW YORKER
THAT WAS DOING HIS JOB AND
SOMEONE WAS EXTREMELY AGGRESSIVE
TOWARDS HIM AND I BELIEVE AFTER
THE D.A.'S REVIEW, THE D.A. IN
MY OPINION MADE THE RIGHT
DECISION.
THE GOAL IS A CONTINUOUS BATTLE
OF MAKING SURE DANGEROUS PEOPLE
THAT ARE ARRESTED ARE
PROSECUTED, GO THROUGH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND OFF
OUR STREETS.
IF WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS
CATCH, RELEASE, REPEAT MIND-SET,
WE'VE GOT TO GET THAT UNDER
CONTROL.
>> Jesse: BEING ABLE TO DEFEND
YOURSELVES IS GETTING MORE
HEADLINES.
MAJOR CRIME IN THE BIG APPLE UP
A WHOPPING 37% OVER THE LAST
YEAR AS VIOLENT CRIME IN CHICAGO
SORT, ARRESTS FELL TO HISTORIC
LOWS.
I THINK, JUDGE, CAN'T THE MAYOR
BE A LITTLE MORE, TO USE HIS
WORDS, AGGRESSIVE WHEN IT COMES
TO KIND OF TAKING SHOTS AT THE
D.A.?
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW,
THIS MAYOR, I'VE SAID IT BEFORE,
HE'S ALL TALKING FOR A GUY WHO
WAS ACTUALLY WALKED THE WALK AS
A POLICE CAPTAIN COMING HE'S ALL
TALK.
THIS IS A GOD, WHAT DID YOU SAY?
[INDISTINCT]
>> Judge Jeanine: I DON'T
CARE.
LET ME EXPLAIN SOMETHING TO YOU.
I WAS A PROSECUTOR AND A JUDGE
FOR MORE THAN THREE DECADES.
THIS IS THE KIND OF BEHAVIOR
THAT CAN BE STOPPED.
YOU'VE GOT A D.A. WHO IS A
HALF-WIT.
IT TAKES HIM THREE WEEKS TO
FIGURE THIS OUT?
IT IS ALL ON VIDEO.
YOU'VE GOT A CAREER CRIMINAL
GANG BANGER WHO IS LIMITING A
GUY IN TERMS OF HIS AREA, THAT
CONFINEMENT IN ITSELF ALLOWS A
GUIDE TO USE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
DEFENSE.
HE IS HALF HIS AGE AND TWICE AS
STRONG.
THE DEFENDANT IN THIS CASE, THE
OWNER SAYS, I WANT NO TROUBLE,
HE REASONABLY BELIEVED HIS LIFE
WAS IN DANGER AND HE STABBED
HIM.
PERIOD, END OF STORY, IT IS ON
VIDEO.
MY CONCERN IS FOR ALL THOSE
PEOPLE, ALL THOSE BODEGA OWNERS,
MOM-AND-POP STORES THAT DON'T
HAVE VIDEOS, THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GET THE CITY BEHIND
HIM, TO GET FOX NEWS BEHIND HIM,
TO GET JESSE WATTERS BEHIND HIM.
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT BUT WE ARE
GOING TO GIVE IT A LEGALS
PHONES, WE ARE GOING TO FLY THEM
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'VE GOT
EDUCATION, MEDICATION AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.
WE'VE GOT TO TAKE CARE OF
OURSELVES FIRST AND THAT IS THE
SAD PART.
WHEN THIS MAYOR TALKS BY CATCH
AND RELEASE, WE'VE GOT TO CHANGE
OUR MIND TO.
GET OVER TO ALBANY, TAKE DOWN
AND SAY IF YOU DON'T STOP THIS
CATCH AND RELEASE, WHICH IS
USUALLY A BORDER TERM BUT IT IS
WHAT IS GOING ON NOW WITH
CRIMINALS, THEN YOU ARE GOING TO
BREAK FROM THE DEMOCRATIC
IDEOLOGY.
YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT POLITICIAN
BECAUSE YOU WILL NOT BREAK FROM
THAT.
THIS IS ABOUT RELEASING THEM ON
JAIL AND EVERYONE ELSE BEING A
VICTIM.
AND I'M DONE.
>> Jesse: MAYBE YOU CAN ANSWER
THE JUDGE 'HIS QUESTION, WHY DID
IT TAKE THE D.A. SO LONG TO DROP
THESE CHARGES?
>> Geraldo: I AM ABSOLUTELY A
CRITIC OF THIS DISTRICT ATTORNEY
JUST LIKE I AM AN ADVOCATE OF
THIS MAYOR ADAMS.
I BELIEVE HE'S DOING ALL THE
RIGHT THINGS, SAYING ALL THE
RIGHT THINGS, HE IS TIRELESS,
GOING EVERYWHERE.
HE WAS EARLY ON THIS, HE KNEW
THAT WAS SELF-DEFENSE EVEN
BEFORE THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
DID.
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN HIS OWN
DEFENSE SAID HE DID NOT SEE THE
VIDEO BEFORE THEY CHARGED
ATTEMPTED MURDER OR MURDER 2,
RATHER, IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE.
LISTEN, NEW YORK IS A GREAT BIG
MACHINE.
A MILLION PEOPLE, IT TAKES A
WHILE TO CHANGE THESE TRENDS.
WE HAD MAYOR de BLASIO FOR
EIGHT YEARS AND THE WORST
POSSIBLE LEADERSHIP, HANDS OFF,
DON'T PUT HIM IN RIKERS ISLAND,
IT IS TOO ARDUOUS, DRACONIAN IN
THEIR, NEW YORK IS COMING
AROUND.
NEW YORK IS COMING AROUND.
THIS WAS A SELF-DEFENSE CASE, NO
ONE DISPUTES THAT NOW.
IT WAS REASONABLE BELIEF THAT HE
NEEDED TO USE FORCE TO SAVE HIS
OWN LIFE AND I THINK AS GRUESOME
AS IT IS LET THIS BE AN EXAMPLE
THAT THE BODEGAS ARE NOW GOING
TO FIGHT BACK.
NOT ONLY ARE THEY GOING TO FIGHT
BACK BUT THE CITY ADMINISTRATION
IS GOING TO BE BEHIND THEM, THE
NEIGHBORHOOD WATCHES ARE GOING
TO BE BEHIND THEM, THE OTHER
BODEGA OWNERS ARE BEHIND THEM,
THE COMMUNITY WILL REJECT THE
NOTION THAT THESE THIEVES, THESE
ARROGANT, ENTITLED THIEVES CAN
HAVE FREE REIGN.
>> Jesse: GERALDO MENTIONED
THE D.A. DIDN'T EVEN LOOK AT THE
VIDEO BEFORE CHARGING THE GUY
WITH MURDER, DANA.
WHY RUSH A CHARGE?
ONE I'LL JUST WAIT UNTIL YOU
HAVE ALL THE EVIDENCE COLLECTED
AND THEN MAKE A DECISION?
>> Dana: THIS IS A GOOD
OUTCOME TODAY, THIS IS JUST AS
TODAY, BUT IT WAS REALLY DELAYED
AND THAT IS ALMOST -- NOT ONLY
DID THEY CHARGE HIM WITH
SECOND-DEGREE MURDER BUT THEY
TOOK THEM STRAIGHT TO RIKERS
PRISON.
HIS STAB WOUNDS FROM THE
GIRLFRIEND WHO STILL DID NOT GET
CHARGED, THEY GOT INFECTED AND
THIS IS A GUY WHO IS NOW, WHERE
DOES HE GET HIS APOLOGY?
AND ALSO THANK GOODNESS FOR
"THE NEW YORK POST," FOX NEWS
AND RETIRED NYPD INSPECTOR WROTE
A PIECE FOR FOXNews.com THAT
HELPED LAY THIS OUT, WHERE WAS
NANCY PELOSI, WHERE WAS
CHUCK SCHUMER?
WHERE WAS "THE NEW YORK TIMES"?
AND YOU WANT TO SEE THE CITY
FLOURISH AND COME BACK TO WORK
THEN YOU HAVE TO START FIGURING
OUT A WAY TO PUT PRESSURE ON
ALVIN BRAGG IS FINALLY THE MAYOR
DID.
I THINK THIS WAS A GOOD OUTCOME
BUT I THINK HE DESERVES AN
APOLOGY ESPECIALLY FOR THE TRIP
TO RIKERS.
HE DID NOT DESERVE THAT.
>> Jesse: WHERE WAS AOC?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW WHEN THE
OTHER POINT IS GOFUNDME DROP TO
THE CAMPAIGN TO HELP THIS GUY
BUT THEY ARE STILL HELPING OUT A
LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE LAW.
WHAT YOU SAID COME OF THE
DECISION TO DUMP THESE CHARGES
WASN'T BASED ON ANY POLITICIAN
OR ANYTHING BUT PUBLIC OUTRAGE.
THIS IS A REMINDER THAT IF YOU
WANT TO STOP THE INSANITY YOU
CAN.
I THINK THE BODEGA OWNERS COMING
TOGETHER, I HAVE TO TAKE CREDIT
FOR 90% OF THE OF THIS.
>> Jesse: YOU DESERVE IT.
>> Greg: I AM A TIRELESS
ADVOCATE.
YOU JUST BROUGHT UP,
"THE NEW YORK POST," WE ARE
GETTING TO THE MOMENT NOW WHERE
STORIES STICK WITH YOU BECAUSE
WE LIVE IN THIS FAST-PACED WORLD
WHERE HORRIBLE CRIMES ARE
HAPPENING EVERY DAY.
HOW MUCH TIME TO BE SPENT ON THE
RACE CAR DRIVER OR OLYMPIC
ATHLETE?
>> Dana: ON LAW AND ORDER.
>> Greg: SO I THINK THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU ACCEPT
PROGRESSIVE RHETORIC WITHOUT
CHECKING UNDER THE HOOD.
WE ARE ALL SO SCARED OF
QUESTIONING THINGS THAT SOUND
COMPASSIONATE, LIKE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM.
WHO IS NOT FOR THAT?
THAT IS GREAT, CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM, EVERYONE LIKES REFORM
EXCEPT IT BENEFITED THE
CRIMINALLY AND NOT THE VICTIM.
IT WAS NEW TO REIGN IN MY
LIFETIME, THE FIRST TIME IN
HISTORY WHERE WE FLIPPED THE
SCRIPT AND PUT THE VICTIMIZERS
BEFORE THE VICTIMS.
IT IS ALL NOW ABOUT RADICAL
WORSHIPING OF THE OPPRESSED WHEN
IN FACT THEY ARE ACTUALLY
CRIMINALS.
AGAIN, WHERE ARE THE FEMINIST
GROUPS WHEN THE MAJORITY OF
THESE VICTIMS ARE WOMEN?
WE HAD TWO WOMEN
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED LAST NIGHT,
EARLY MORNING IN THE STREETS OF
NEW YORK AND YOU JUST NEVER SEE
BECOME AWARE OF THE FEMINIST
GROUPS WHEN THE MAJORITY OF THE
VICTIMS ARE WOMEN BY PSYCHOPATHS
PUSHING THEM IN FRONT OF TRAINS,
PUSHING THEM DOWNSTAIRS, HITTING
THEM WITH OBJECTS.
WHERE ARE THE CUSTOMER GETS A
FAIR QUESTION.
I MEAN, THE GOVERNOR IS GOING
BACK AND FORTH ON HER
HELICOPTER, AND ALBANY TO GOD
KNOWS WHERE.
WHAT IS SHE DOING COSMIC
NOTHING.
SHE SHOULD FIRE ALVIN BRAGG NOW
OR WE ARE GOING TO FIRE HER.
SPEAKING OF WHICH, de BLASIO.
>> Jesse: de BLASIO IS OUT.